alright let's try our next caller from
the three two one
area code caller from three two one are
you there hello who's this okay hear me
we can hear you that's Michael Michael -
it great
I was wondering with the vicious cycles
that are happening in today's youth with
especially with the opioid epidemic and
how people today take these prescription
pills and they get into an addiction
then whenever the pills stop coming they
get to these harder drugs and then those
harder drugs spread out to the youth -
my generation at what point does the
u.s. look at its system on on the war on
drugs and go we have failed on this and
we should probably look at other places
that have better succeeded in this world
on drugs such as Portugal where they
have lowered their HIV rates through
through the the legalization and heroin
the heroin epidemic in Portugal has now
been substantially lowered because of
this right you are inflating a couple
different issues so number one is the
sort of war on drug status quo and to
answer the question when does the u.s.
seriously rethink that it's when our
priorities change away from using the
war on drugs to derive law enforcement
revenue and to incarcerate people so
that that would need to change for us to
seriously rethink the war on drugs
you're also referring to this cycle that
exists within opiates which is where
people are often ending up addicted to
heroin because they end up buying
painkillers on the streets because they
were prescribed painkillers by a doctor
often over prescribed and with not
enough supervision and that is a circle
that we need to interrupt and it's
related to the war on drugs but it's
also sort of its own problem Michael
okay and what could we do as a society
to bring actual change to do these
problems
there's a couple different things I mean
certainly you've got a D you have to
decriminalize drugs you have to make
drugs an issue of public health rather
than of criminality and of law
enforcement there's no question that you
also need to reschedule certain drugs
the current scheduling of drugs makes
absolutely no sense the idea of
cannabis/marijuana scheduled as a
Schedule one drug when I believe cocaine
is a schedule 2 drug at this time that
doesn't make sense so there's a lot of
really specific changes that could be
made that I've talked about but we
really need to have a wholesale
reorganization of how we deal with drugs
is there any way to change how the
police force is getting paid so then
these no not even morally wrong
infractions are not taken upon the youth
and basically screwing over their entire
lives because of petty petty a marijuana
offense yes certainly decriminalization
and also you've got a deal also with
diversion programs you can't be putting
young kids into the system and then
basically saying to them you're going to
be part of the system indefinitely right
that that's what you're saying to a kid
when they're 17 and they start to
interact with the law enforcement system
over something like drug possession no
doubt about it